everyone i've talked to who said they
used to be a liberal who then became
conservative voted for trump or
are just you know no longer part of the
woke cult or whatever
it was because they started doing their
own research they started reading
the quotes they started watching the
videos and so while social media may
create incentives for people to create
you know to push cancel culture
and exacerbate the problem it also
creates the opportunity
the political bias of the legacy media
becomes more and more obvious every day
as they seek to deceive the american
people
in response the public has begun to turn
to members of replacement media
those who bring with them the truth
without a covert agenda one of the most
popular voices to arise from this
movement
is our guest today journalist
commentator and youtuber tim poole
tim first came into the public view with
his on-the-ground journalism live
streaming the occupy movements of 2011.
whatever was happening seemed to be
important it seemed to be interesting a
lot of people were talking about it a
few years later
we joined vice media field reporting
from conflict areas around the world
his work has found new traction recently
however now that the conflicts have come
to the home front
tim has spent the last few years largely
focused on the rise of the antifa
movement
or perhaps more so on the media's
complete lack of attention
to the violent and fascist tactics that
movement employs
tim has been on the front lines of
exposing the radical left and the lying
media
a former bernie sanders supporter tim
raised eyebrows this year with his
emphatic support for donald trump
while not condoning all of the
president's actions he saw trump as a
vital bulwark for the country
he dives in on this choice in our
conversation tim and i also discussed
the propaganda war raging across the
country
as we wait for the results of the
election including the latest defenses
from legacy media and big tech
and what the future may hold for the
country under a new administration
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special just a
reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions at
the end with tim pool the only way to
get access to that part of the
conversation is to become a member
so head on over to dailywire.com become
a member and you'll have access to all
of the full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests we're going to get
to tim in just one second first
let's be real about this if you're not
protecting yourself from online threats
you are making a big
big mistake not too long ago over 100
million people had their personal
information stolen
in a major data breach social security
numbers contact details
credit scores and more all taken from
capital one customers and it's not just
capital one
equifax ebay uber playstation yahoo
they've all had leaked passwords credit
card info
bank numbers belong to billions of users
if you think hackers only target large
companies to get your information
you are wrong this is why i use
expressvpn to safeguard my personal data
online
now according to some recent reports
hackers can make up to a thousand bucks
from selling someone's personal
information on the dark web
making people like you and me easy and
lucrative targets you've ever been
hacked before it is no fun
expressvpn is an app for your computer
and phone it secures and encrypts your
data so you can have peace of mind every
time you go
online the app connects with just one
click it is lightning fast the best part
is
expressvpn costs less than seven bucks a
month listen if a breach can happen to
capital one it can certainly happen to
you protect yourself with expressvpn it
is the number one vpn rated by
wired cnet the verge and countless
others everybody needs to protect
themselves i've been using expressvpn
for years go check them out right now at
expressvpn.com that is expressvpn.com
ben expr essvpn.com ben
tim poole thanks so much for joining the
show thanks for having me i really
appreciate it
yeah i know this has been long awaited
on the interwebs this this final
final confrontation so let's let's talk
about what's going on in the world right
now
uh obviously aside from the fact that
everybody is still locked in their
basement because of covid which we'll
get to
we're still in the middle of an election
uh this this has been declared over by
the media the media have said that this
thing is over not only have they
declared
that joe biden is the president elect
they have declared
that anybody who refuses to call him the
president-elect even though he's not
actually yet the president-elect
is engaged in some sort of coup what do
you make of all of this
i mean it's it's kind of a tradition
that the media would say hey here's the
winner
it's projected and they just go along
with it but i think
it's kind of a millennial bias we're so
used to seeing these elections aside
from bush v gore
where the results are kind of clear you
know mitt romney didn't get nearly
enough votes so he just says okay i
concede
but this is a really really close race i
mean we're within recount of
uh numbers for certain states georgia
just announced a hand recount
so it's not necessarily it doesn't
really make sense to say
joe biden won when there's a legal
process you know happening
several states are too close to call
still i
the media has just decided this is it
joe biden won it's over
meanwhile i think they're starting to
wake up to the fact that trump has
i think he actually has a legal path to
victory there was an article put up by
vox
recently showing all the ways that trump
is still planning on taking this to
court
maybe disqualifying certain votes maybe
getting a victory through the electoral
college by having
republicans at the state level certify
their own
electors so trump's certainly not out of
this and i got to tell you it's kind of
weird seeing
these two different realities where you
have one media apparatus saying
president-elect joe biden announces his
covet plans
then you see another one saying donald
trump is in court right now
challenging you know the results in
certain states or
uh impropriety at a certain level so
it's all it's almost like
they're trying to tell us joe biden one
to convince us
because it's not over certification
hasn't happened for the states yet let
alone
for the the you know the election as a
whole and then choosing the electors
the level of hysteria to me is the thing
that really stands out
and it seems to me that the media are
basically addicts that donald trump is
their cocaine
and and they can't let go of it and so
they they require
just this constant addiction that they
require a constant supply
of chaos i also think there's something
else going on here too which is they
keep saying that trump is about to
participate in a coup that let's say the
electors vote for joe biden he's going
to hole up
in the oval office like al pacino at the
end of scarface he's going to be doing
blow and firing guns through the door
and while shouting say hello to my
little friend
and i i think this has much more to do
with the media's pathological need to
paint trump as hitler so they can do
whatever they want
than it does with reality yeah i think
so i mean
i will say when i i think it was michael
moore who said it a while ago trump's
not gonna leave even if he loses
and i was like get out of here that's
ridiculous i mean
i think right now what's happening is
they're they're putting forth this media
narrative the election's over
so they can now be like see look he's
not leaving even though the election's
over
when it's not but i i will say trump's
taken some actions it appears that he's
not planning on leaving
this could just be because he's going
through the legal process and until
all of his legal uh you know tactics
have played out
he's going to operate as though he's
going to get elected but i do think at
this point the idea that
yeah like you mentioned trump's going to
be locked in the oval office the secret
service is going to kick the door in is
just
ridiculous but at this point i got to be
honest i'm ready to believe anything
you know just the amount of absurdity
we've seen throughout 2020
we're not we're in a global pandemic
they're starting to lock down different
states now so
maybe it really is just going to be the
craziest
election we've ever seen in our lives
but i don't know i feel like life is
more boring than that so
yeah i do too i mean i think that one of
the things that that we find out the
more we're into the political sphere is
that
politics is a lot less like house of
cards and a lot more like veep
that there's this assumption on the part
of people who are outside the world of
politics that people know what they're
doing that there are these very
sophisticated plans and that
people have thought three steps down the
road and they're all playing 4d chess
and it turns out that just like in every
other industry when you hit the top of
the industry you realize that
everybody's an idiot just like you
uh and that that is pretty much i think
how it works in politics
yeah especially i i think when i was
younger i was talking about this
recently
i used to look up to all these adults
they must be so good at what they do
they must be the best of the best and
man when i'm when i'm older now i'm you
know in my mid-30s and i'm like
everyone's as dumb as they've always
been
you know it's just people doing people
stuff you think that you walk into this
election center and you're gonna see a
whole bunch
of experts with their badges and they're
wearing gloves and everything's perfect
now you got some regular guy who's
volunteering and he's confused
you get sworn affidavits from some
people because they don't know what's
going on and it's just
humans it's it's not like a well-oiled
machine necessarily it's not like a
computer it's a bunch of
people with different perspectives and
different understandings and different
skills
trying to work together so i think for
the most part though when you you put
enough people together you get some
really amazing stuff
but you'll see errors you'll see
impropriety and stuff
and so i think you know especially now
with the election one of the biggest
mistakes the media is making which
i think could actually lead to serious
chaos maybe conflict
is that recognizing humans are imperfect
you're gonna find a bunch of people
saying
in a sworn affidavit i saw this thing
happen you can't just ignore that
and say we will do nothing you you have
to let people know
we're doing everything in our power to
clean up any potential errors
so they view this election as legitimate
i mean if joe biden
really does get certified as the winner
he gets inaugurated
but they don't look into this stuff it
would undermine his presidency
because you've got 72.2 million people
now who have voted for donald trump
i think everybody deserves to look at
these affidavits or these whistleblowers
and just
say you know is it is it going to change
the election
maybe it won't but we should investigate
and i will also add too i think
you know donald trump's legal path to
victory right now it's almost like he's
dangling fraud
over on like to his left and you got all
the media
saying there's no evidence of fraud
you've got the activists saying fraud
but trump's lawsuits are about
impropriety
his lawsuits in pennsylvania at least is
about
equal the equal protection clause under
the 14th amendment that's nothing to do
with fraud it has everything to do with
they didn't count bouts properly or they
created an alternate track of ballots
or they violated a court order so while
you've got these people over here
dancing around screaming fraud
trump is actually taking a legal battle
over whether or not he can disqualify
hundreds of thousands of votes due to
you know failure to uphold election
standards i think there's also something
else going on here too which is the
because we always live in the stupidest
possible timeline until we break down
into these
binary positions the positions have now
become on the right
voter fraud is widespread it is in the
tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of votes and on the left
there's no such thing as voter fraud
i've never heard of this voter fraud
thing you're talking about voter
irregularities don't exist
in the slightest and it's amazing how
those positions completely reversed from
about a month ago when a month ago all
we were hearing from democrats is that
donald trump was personally going around
and burning mailboxes in order to
prevent people from depositing their
votes because he was that committed to
voter suppression at lewis de joy
screwing with the machines that the
votes wouldn't be properly delivered or
accounted he was defunding the post
office
and now everybody who was saying one
month ago that the election was gonna be
totally screwed up is now saying
look what an amazingly clean
unbelievably awesome election we had
and everybody a month ago was going you
know what the election's probably going
to be okay they're all like
god that was just the worst most
fraudulent election i've ever seen in my
life
you know what's crazy is when we did the
primaries where we had these mass
mail-in voting we had a massive
amount of rejected ballots i think the
washington post had like 500 000
where are all of those right now that's
what i was wondering
you know shouldn't shouldn't we be
getting these same reports we got from
the democratic primary we're not getting
those
so i think you got human error you've
got you're going to get some level of
failure
but i think you hit the nail on the head
there's there's this weird tribalist
polarization that we see
and it's happened in other places in the
world when you get people
i don't want to get too specific because
i don't want to call any specific
regions out but there are some instances
where you're like
how does that one group believe the
exact opposite of the other group when
neither position makes the most sense
so i i think a better real real world
example is when covid first
hit the us i knew a bunch of
conservatives saying
get your masks like you've got to wear
your masks but we were seeing you know
fauci
and i think the surgeon general saying
no no no don't don't get masks
then it completely flipped now you see
videos of you know it's trump supporters
saying i'm not going to wear a mask i
shouldn't have to
and you've got people on the left saying
everyone should wear a mask
it seems like for tribal reasons somehow
it flipped just
whatever you say i'll do the opposite of
so you're really
on reverse course here and kind of
provide some background on you for
people who may not have heard your show
or or seen your youtube videos so you're
really heterodox thinker you don't
really fit into any box people will call
you on the left people have called you
progressive people called you right wing
it all depends on who is doing the
characterization so why don't we talk
first about sort of
how you came to do what you're doing
right now and then we'll talk about how
your political views
were formed over time because they do
seem to to move and evolve over time in
a way that's really unique in the space
so first i think that you know to talk
about you know
kind of how you came to prominence in
this in this space in the first place
uh my my first uh experience seeing some
of your stuff was during the occupy wall
street protest when you were the only
person who was out there actually taking
footage and covering that stuff
um but how did you get started in this
area well it started with occupy wall
street
so i had been doing non-profit work
i had you know i've been hanging out
with hackers and this was back in like
the days of anonymous
and some other hacker groups and so the
big core ideology behind
what we did and why we did it and it was
mostly other people i wasn't super
active
was making sure people had access to
information be it get them the internet
or give them the key details as to
what's going on
and then all of a sudden you had these
journalists say well that's journalism
you're sharing information you're
disseminating that stuff
so for me i ended up on the east coast
and then when i saw occupy wall street
happened i was just some you know
i just left california i'm just some guy
who's skateboarding and making videos
and i decided to go
and start filming eventually start live
streaming
and while i'm streaming i'm giving my
thoughts on what's happening and
essentially doing this raw live
commentary i had this big moment where i
did a live stream for 22 hours straight
people were like running up to find me
to give me batteries to keep it going
and then i started just covering
conflict in crisis
from there i went from some guy who's
live streaming these protests to
actually working for vice
and being i was the founding member of
vice news the like the actual vertical
where i went on the ground to various uh
countries you know like venezuela like
turkey brazil
went to egypt watch the revolution
happen and i was just covering the
conflict and crisis stuff there
eventually the conflicting crisis came
to the u.s
so i ended up working for a company
called fusion they
they started out trying to be like vice
and this is a this was at a time as 2014
when these companies all started getting
super woke
i've never been particularly interested
in you know the weird cultural far-left
stuff
even though i saw it at occupy wall
street i was like i think that's kind of
ridiculous
so i ended up working with this company
but within seven or eight months
they got a new editor-in-chief all of a
sudden everything they're doing is woke
so they essentially put me in you know
what we call golden handcuffs
i was getting real i was paid really
well to work for this you know disney
company
but they didn't want to use real like
on-the-ground
conflict reporting because they wanted
to do video segments about you know woke
stuff i guess
but ultimately my contract ended i
started doing my own youtube channel
and i started by actually traveling
around so i went to sweden
i did a two-week like daily vlog from
sweden interviewing people seeing what
was going on
this was when donald trump did that
there was that famous moment where he
said last night in sweden you see what
happened
and the media went nuts that was a crazy
moment for me because all of a sudden
i had my colleagues from vice who used
to help me go
to these countries messaging me saying
don't go to sweden to cover the story
and i was confused why wouldn't i like i
went to egypt
i went to ukraine i went to a bunch of
countries no no but don't do this one
trump's lying and i'm like i don't know
i don't know anything about this i don't
know anything about trump or what he's
talking about
i just heard there are some claims about
you know refugees and crime i'm gonna go
and investigate it
that was they got really really mad at
me and that was when i could see like
this weird split starting to emerge so
from there
i come back to the u.s and i started
covering the conflicts we see on the
ground in the u.s you know proud boys
anti-fun that kind of stuff
and of course what do i see 99 percent
of the time
you get some trump supporters waving
little american flags and antifa shows
up and attacks them
i would report it antifa would get
really mad at me
so they started threatening me doxxing
me i someone posted a photo of my mom at
one point
and so that was like for me i think
i already had some you know personal
biases going back to my upbringing in
chicago
but now it's all i'm trying to do is
cover what's happening on the ground and
by telling the truth
these extremists and like antifa type
people were attacking me and threatening
me
and that i mean was kind of uh
i guess to be expected but it did set me
up on a path where
for one i couldn't actually go on the
ground anymore so i i slowly stopped
doing it
because it was getting more and more
dangerous so then i started doing more
and more
news commentary and analysis to kind of
make up
for the fact that i couldn't be on the
ground you know aggregate more of the
people who actually are doing the work
and i kind of feel like it's not a
completely uncommon track for
journalists to go
from field reporter and then eventually
later in their career they find
themselves as like a news commentary
kind of person
and then uh once it just became
completely obvious that
you know it happened when i went to
portland i had some guy chasing me
around
yelling like while i'm trying to film
and i'm like okay
clearly i got you know too many people
know who i am they're seeking me out
they're causing trouble they're trolling
or they're actually attacking me
so i'm gonna have to stop coming to a
lot of these events
and then just report to the best of my
abilities from the desk
i just started increasing the amount of
work i started doing i started doing
multiple segments per day now i think
i do um an hour and 45 minutes of direct
commentary and i do a total of like
i do an additional two hours of a live
podcast show which brings me to this
position where now i'm kind of this i
think as you mentioned like a heterodox
individual don't really fit necessarily
anywhere
uh although i think i've been classified
as like cultural right wing
whatever that means but my political
positions
are kind of just like where democrats
used to be it's a weird position to be
in
i will say i think the easiest way to
explain that i'm not
orthodox i suppose in some capacity like
a heterodox personality is
whenever they try and smear people who
are
you know like like right now you got a
lot of people on podcasts and youtube
for instance
that are saying the election's not over
you get these articles saying
or cnn for instance you've got the the
right-wing media
lying claim the election's not over but
they never mention me
because if they do they show you like
you know my segments are actually very
i don't know i don't i don't say bland
but uh the the joke is that i'm a milk
toast fence sitter
i will tell you we have a sworn
affidavit from numerous you know poll
watchers
but i'm not going to come out and scream
the election was stolen and
and and trump won i'm just going to say
we should investigate this it doesn't
really work very well for
the mainstream media to smear me as some
kind of conspiracy theorist
when i don't make an assertion beyond
here's a fact so
ultimately i find myself in this weird
position where for one if you go to
like my my flagship channel with the
most subscribers it's like basically
the media is trash and the democrats are
too so then people see that and they say
tim pool must be right wing
but then when it comes to actual policy
like my politics are probably you know
independent center left and i disagree
with conservatives on a lot of core
issues
that result in trump supporters getting
mad at me it's a weird position i don't
know but
ultimately that's where i'm at now and
then i guess at some point ben shapiro
hit me up and asked me to come on his
show so
yeah so i want to talk with you about uh
you know you obviously were covering
antifa
you've covered in detail uh black lives
matter and you mentioned sort of the
woke phenomenon i don't talk about the
phenomenon and then i want to talk about
what i think is actually a more
important issue which is the meta
phenomenon of how how social media and
the media refuse to cover this
phenomenon how they have decided that
certain narratives are
worth cultivating and certain narratives
must be barred certain narratives must
be suppressed
uh because to me that is the the scarier
uh
the scarier phenomenon is sort of the
mainstream deciding what we can and
cannot see
there's there's the radicals and they're
scary but they're kind of a small
proportion of the population then you
actually have like this mainstream
phenomenon
of attempting to quash any discussion of
the radicalism which
effectively makes them enablers we'll
get to that in one second first
let's talk about a simple fact it is
your responsibility to take care
of your family and get life insurance
right are you a responsible human being
with dependence you need
life insurance in case god forbid
something should happen if you get hit
by a bus you want to make sure
that your family at least is taken care
of financially now shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
but
if you have loved ones who depend on you
it is really important that's why policy
genius makes it easy
they combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time and save you
money
right now you could say 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really start to add up
here's how it works first you head on
over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape
the best part they work for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius
a five-star rating across over 1600
reviews on trustpilot and
google go check them out right now if
you need life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and important to get it right
so let's talk about antifa so you
covered antifa on the ground we've been
told by the media that antifa
are alternatively world war ii era
allied troops storming the beaches of
normandy uh we've been told by joe biden
that they are not in fact a group
that they are in fact just sort of a
philosophy you know sort of like
sort of like cubism or something like an
artistic movement well what exactly is
antifa since you've covered them on the
ground
it's a uh i mean it's not necessarily
wrong to say that they're a movement or
an idea but it's the individual cells
that we're talking about i think what
you're talking about
and what they do is the mainstream media
uses a semantic argument to try and act
like they don't exist so
to put it simply antifa is the symbols
they use the ideology
typically you'll find many of these
people are
authoritarian communists and i'm not
trying to exaggerate or do some stupid
oh they're all communists not like
they're literally they believe in
authoritarian communism but
uh it's it's rooted in you know world
war pre-world war ii germany
weimar germany where you had the
communist party had their anti fishy
stay action
and it was challenging the fascists they
use the same symbols
they create small individual groups with
they say no leaders they have leaders
they do and then they coordinate
for various actions they call them
nationwide so ultimately what you have
are political zealots who believe in the
use of violence for political gain and
terror
for political gain what they'll do is
they'll tell you
and they'll have allies in media tell
you there's no such thing as antifa it's
not a group
well that's a semantic manipulation
they're playing a game here
if i say anti-fuck came out in portland
and attack people
i'm talking about rose city antifa it's
a legitimate group
they have membership they have
membership drives they put out
you know flyers or they put out a
website saying here's how you join our
group
they have their own merchandise that
says rose city antifa on it
so it would be like you know the media
is trying to use
a word play to trick you into believing
that these various groups don't exist
because if i said you know i went to
portland and antifa came out then i went
to boston and antifa came out they say
ah see that proves it
because there's no connection between
those two groups but it's
the general ideas they they they hold
that same ideology
wearing all black these similar tactics
they use the same symbols
and they typically agree with each other
on their cause
and their you know their means to the
end so you actually have
a loose-knit group of various cells that
coordinate with each other using
violence against their political
opponents
for the most part instigating it
outright to to
to win and it works for them you know
the example i often give to people
why is it that social media is so
willing to censor
right-wing individuals but anti-fuzz
literally organizing
violent riots online even probably right
now they've been doing it
you know all year and for the past
several years and it's simple
antifa in say san francisco in the bay
area
they'll show up to the to the
headquarters of these big tech companies
and they'll trash the place
so these companies say well well you
know leave them alone but
there's not going to be a conservative
group marching to twitter hq with
pitchforks and torches
so long as big companies keep giving
antifa what they want or showing them
their tactics work
they'll keep doing what they do as for
the loosenet nature of what they do it's
all on purpose
the reason why they don't have an
official nationwide organization is very
it's
it's actually really easy to understand
when you look at the proud boys
obviously the proud boys in antifa are
not the same things but there are
similarities in that you have these
these groups that fight on this on the
ground
the proud boys have a chairman enrique
tario well they've banned him from
dozens of banks they've banned him from
all these different platforms you give
someone a leader
they use that to actually try and
discredit the rest of your group
antifa knows this i've actually talked
to people going back to occupy wall
street who have straight up said
no leaders as soon as you put someone up
they'll smear they'll character
assassinate
so it is on purpose they say they don't
have leaders
however law enforcement knows who the
individual cell leaders are i would
imagine
and i think some of them got doxed
recently so it's really it's it's not
you know their tactics aren't perfect
but i will say the left is much much
better at street level organizing than
the right
and so you end up with a media narrative
that can't understand what antifa is or
outright defends them on purpose
i think there's there's two things
you've got the activist media that hates
donald trump and
they're saying you know oh antifa is no
big deal but they're saying it because
they want to protect antifa you then
have these local reporters these people
who are probably
you know they have good intentions
they're trying to be objective and fair
but they can't grasp the concept of
antifa as a group
because antifa has specifically
obfuscated what they really are
so you can't report on what they are
then you get someone like say andy no
or elijah schaefer someone like at one
point what i was doing
and we can actually accurately break it
down and report on the ground they get
really angry about that
and we all saw what happened to andy
know you know when he was out there in
portland they physically beat him they
left him bleeding and covered in you
know milkshake and stuff like that
those are the people they're really
worried about but long story short
they're they're radical far left they
typically are authoritarian communists
but not all of them some of them might
just be
they might be like left anarchist i know
there's a big debate over whether or not
anarchists can actually be left or right
but
they view themselves that way they'll
view themselves as socialists but the
big the big issue i see with antifa
is that you might find someone who will
try and lie and justify no no we don't
believe in violence where it's
self-defense
but these are the narratives they like
to use to get away with what they do and
so long as you have these mainstream
resistance type democrats who hate trump
they won't call these groups out
and that's been something i've
experienced going back to occupy wall
street
where the peaceful legitimate protesters
are told by these groups to respect
their quote diversity of tactics it's
this it's the stupidest idea i've ever
heard
the idea that you're going to engage in
some kind of strategy against a big
system but diversify what that strategy
is makes no sense you want to have a
cohesive plan
as to how you're going to make change
happen the the reality is these groups
say respect our diversity of tactics
because
that's code for getting violent and
hurting people and then you get these
good-natured protesters who just want to
you know wave their little signs and
banners and be heard
now standing back as antifa messes with
people knocks them down starts fires
so i will say i think antifa for the
most part is a colloquial term we use to
describe
the far left extremists who use what's
called a black bloc tactic
where you know they wear hoodies they
wear masks i don't know what we'll call
them in the future we just called them
the black block anarchists
you know 10 years ago now they're antifa
they're still here they're still
rioting apparently the media calling it
for joe biden did nothing to change
their minds and in fact i think
it's only it's only likely to escalate
as if if we do enter a joe biden
administration because
certainly joe biden won't be strong
enough to deal with these groups that
are pressuring him and attacking him and
getting violent and we already saw this
i believe recently they attacked a dnc
headquarters saying f joe biden
so anyway there you go i think i've
ranted too much on what antifa is but we
can you know follow up
that's i think very useful for people
who sort of have a vague idea but but
not a very specific
idea uh and then meanwhile we've seen
the media
basically decide that you are never
allowed to criticize not only antifa but
also black lives matter black lives
matter itself is considered to be
uh a wonderful movement there's been a
game that you mentioned there this sort
of semantic overload that has been
placed on the term black lives matter
which as i've pointed out in my show
means three separate things one of which
is completely unobjectionable and two of
which are rather objectionable
one of which is the idea that black
people's lives matter which of course
everybody agrees with unless you're a
complete piece of human
track second the black lives matter
actual organization which is a far left
communist organization
in its inception and openly states its
goals and third the
basic underlying idea that america's
systemically racist evil since root
and that all in all inequality is at
root inequity which i think is uh both
counterproductive and false
but we've been told that to even
question black lives matter is to
itself be be racist and that if you are
to pay attention to any of the
any of the riots around the country
that's just exaggerating the problem i
mean after all only seven percent of the
black lives matter protests
erupted into riots which is uh a pretty
shocking only
and that that word only is doing a lot
of work in that particular sentence
right they also they also didn't explain
that i think of that seven percent
there was like numerous cities
constantly being besieged by this so
they were like
you know my i could be wrong about this
but counting one city's widespread
rioting as just one protest
but yeah i think it's funny if you said
something like you know uh
john smith only kills seven percent of
the people he encounters you'd be like
that's ridiculous or
or maybe killing people is a bit extreme
what if he said don't worry about bill
he he doesn't punch 93 percent of the
people he encounters i'd be like he
shouldn't punch any of them
it's really weird how they tried oh it's
peaceful i'm like so you're admitting
it's not like that's that's weird
these are these are violent riots and
another thing they didn't mention is
that
in many of these cities where they say
there were peaceful protests they would
separate when the riot happened from the
protest and act like
oh no this day was was a peaceful
protest even though the same people were
there
doing much of the same thing on this day
the police didn't say
there was riots or there was violence
and so it's it's really difficult to
weed through
exactly what's going on but i will say
peaceful protests are awesome
it's it's it's foundational to this
country um the first amendment says
peacefully uh you know a peaceably
assemble
and i think it's fantastic when people
go out and do so and to varying degrees
i'm i'm totally cool with even civil
disobedience
if they want to block traffic okay you
get arrested you get your your your fine
your slap on the wrist
you made your point we heard you we want
to make sure there's room for people to
actually
express themselves protest and so early
on we did see with black lives matter
there were things where they would just
lay in the street with their hands
behind their back
i thought that was really cool everybody
knew it was coming they expected it they
avoided certain routes
then these people went home and they
made their point and that actually
benefits them in the polls
it generates public awareness as it's
supposed to and it makes people
sympathetic
but then we get these these extremists
who think they're you know
la resistance fighting against orange
hitler to like take down a federal
building which is made of like
hundreds or thousands of tons of
concrete they're throwing fire like you
know mortar shells at it
it's like they're playing a game they're
live-action role-playing they're not
aware
they're not actually doing anything but
i will say what i find funny about
you know the black lives matter stuff
we've seen this past year is they're
mostly white
it's it's it's it's mostly upper middle
class suburban white young progressives
saying they're fighting for minorities
you end up with these videos where
there's two black women walking up to
these
these two white women who are
vandalizing a building and they're like
why are you doing this and they're like
don't worry we're doing it for you
and it's like there's there's there's no
intention
in my opinion you know when we talk we
talk about the three different black
lives matter you mentioned
it's mostly used as some kind of
shield for radical far leftists
who are they're they're trying to
convince people we're the good guys
because racism is bad
but when they go out and they destroy
businesses in black neighborhoods they
clearly don't care
when they accuse actual outspoken black
people say candace owens of being a
white supremacist they clearly don't
care
they're using race as a shield while
they engage in racist or violent
behavior
and then they use these it's a really
really clever uh trick that
these leftists do anti-fascist you know
we are anti-fascists therefore if you
oppose us you're pro-fascist
it's like dude you're walking around
beating people then they say we're we're
for black lives matter that's our group
if you oppose us you think they don't
it's like well
clearly that's not the case you're going
around smashing things and beating
people and actually
hurting the black community it's it's
all just clever word play
and i think it's all built upon
manipulating the media they want the
media to rep
actually let me stop i'll put it this
way i decided i'm going to start an
organization
called the weak invulnerable
grandmothers
that way when my organization of you
know 30 year old men go around
yelling things the media will report
antifa attacks weaken vulnerable
grandmothers
that's like an idea of what they're
doing so it's it's it's
it's a trick most people just read the
headline they just
they don't actually investigate what the
story is so i get people telling me
things all the time
like oh but they're anti-fascists
they're the good guys i'm like did you
see the video of them beating the old
woman
they're like oh no i didn't actually
read it well that's that's that's the
name
it's it's the name anti-fascist it's not
the action and the actions are what you
need to look for
so i want to talk about the the broader
danger of these movements which i don't
think is the actual movements i think it
is the mainstreaming of
of the movements by more mainstream
groups the democratic party the the
mainstream
media and and social media to me what's
happening in a lot of left-wing politics
right now
it's almost like the uh the stories that
you read in the newspapers and
online about you know some elderly
hollywood star who's aging and doesn't
like aging and so
has hired a 20 year old and is now
siphoning off their blood in order to uh
cycle it through their system and they
believe that the oxygenated blood will
make them
more healthy over time i i feel like
right now that's sort of the democratic
party with the woke and with the radical
like well this is where all the energy
is and we don't want to quash the energy
so we're going to allow that energy to
fester
and they'll leave us alone because we
mostly agree with them so long as we
direct that energy
you know at the bad people at the orange
hitler
at the orange man bad and all the
conservatives and it had all the people
online we don't like
well then you know they're really maybe
they're overzealous but they're doing
the right things and eventually they'll
grow out of this and they'll stop
messing around with this
it's it's a really dangerous thing yep
it's it's not gonna stop
they they're they're they're playing
with fire and you know i i gotta be
honest i don't even
think it's the youthful energy i think
it's twitter
i think you've got hyper polarization
due to
places you know social media platforms
like twitter i think twitter is the
worst
it's really hard to get a complex idea
out on twitter so i've mostly just given
up and i just roll with it i laugh when
people take things the wrong way it's
like yeah well whatever
but someone will put something out it'll
be interpreted
interpreted in completely the wrong way
and what twitter does
is it encourages people to be as nasty
as possible
what i see happening is it's also with
facebook it's it's you know with with
keyword stuffing and algorithmic
boosting that we see through facebook
certain posts that have certain words
are more likely to get shares and more
likely to appear
you end up with a very small faction of
hyper
active internet users posting on twitter
trying to get likes
and so what happens is you'll see
ridiculous stories like uh
there was one from the huffington post
that said there may be a video of donald
trump in an elevator doing something
what is that thing we don't know
where is the elevator we have no idea
and does the video exist we're not sure
they actually wrote that article in a
desperate bid
a desperate attempt to just write
something that will get clicks and
shares salacious but they didn't have
anything
so they just wrote nothing but what ends
up happening is you also get cancel
culture
people are rewarded and cheered for when
they're like look at this person who's a
bigot
all of a sudden now we've gamified this
process on social media
you get more points you get more
retweets you get more followers and in
fact you can make money doing this
you'll see people say here's a thread
about why ben shapiro is a nazi
and then they'll put at the bottom
here's my paypal link give me money
they'll take everything you say out of
context the more people share it though
the more misinformed they're becoming
then you get the democratic politicians
who think twitter is real life
and they see those twitter threads and
they say i'm gonna campaign
on this issue about weird social justice
cancel culture
then you get some you know 38 year old
mother who's like are my kids going to
school
why is the guy on tv talking about some
twitter thread what's happening
i think to an extent republicans also
fall victim to this as well i think it's
funny
when they're talking about twitter
censorship you see like you know ted
cruz bring it up i appreciate it because
i use the internet
but i have to wonder if we have only
about 22 percent of this country using
twitter and only i think
it's it's like uh 10 or so 8 of those
are actually active
it must be really weird to be a regular
american turning on the news and then
hearing them talk about
social media culture war issues that
mean nothing to you
which i think may explain you know why
the republicans took so many seats in
the house this time around
and even why donald trump is is is uh
losing to joe biden
as it stands so far i think regular
people are like i don't care about
twitter i don't care about these these
culture war issues
but i do think for the most part it's
the democrats that are mostly
susceptible to it
because they're looking for the youth
vote like you mentioned they're looking
for youthful energy
they're finding it on social media where
the young people are extremely active
and instead of telling them hey just
because your tweet went viral doesn't
mean it was correct or good
they're saying i'll just go with it and
say what they're saying
and then you you end up with really
weird policy positions like
you know bernie sanders in 2015 says we
can't have open borders it's a koch
brothers proposal that was an interview
with vox
now he's on the debate stage you know
just this past year saying moratorium on
deportations and decriminalized border
crossings
he completely flips on what his
principles are
and it's because of the things you you
know people are posting on social media
it doesn't represent america
i think it's interesting trump won in
2016 on a message that seemed to fly in
the face of what
you know social justice was pushing on
social media and it
in my opinion shows with pc culture
being one of the big aspects that people
cite when they say why they voted for
trump
regular people don't care about this
democrats have have
walked themselves into a corner i don't
see how they get themselves out now
you see aoc is is attacking the
democrats
saying you know the house would have
fared better if you just let me lead and
be progressive now you've got jane
cougar of the young turks
writing a wall street journal op-ed
saying let progressives take over
and i can only imagine that would end up
with them losing in the most absurd
defeat ever
because then the republican party
becomes the big tent you end up with
people like jeff
van drew who was a democrat switches to
the republican party wins re-election
these these people don't realize you
know ocasio-cortez may have 10 million
followers on twitter
but those 10 million people don't live
in like one city she doesn't have
command over one massive district
she has little bits little pockets of
individuals from various jurisdictions
that don't hold political power in those
areas
and they're trying to legislate based
off of the fact that
they've created a community of political
zealots on social media that doesn't
represent this country
but they think it does because they've
gathered in this one online space
so long story short expect more as
as the aging democrats don't know what
they're doing as nancy pelosi tries to
placate the squad and then gives them
what they want
refuses to denounce socialism once nancy
pelosi and feinstein and and schumer and
adler once they they're
they're all out all that's going to be
left is the twitter politicians
the people who want to be celebrities
who want to do instagram live videos get
as many clicks as possible
i don't see them legislating i see them
trying to do things that are funny and
get them clicks and shares on twitter
and social media
and i think aoc exemplifies you know
i'll put it this way just to make
everybody angry i think aoc is very much
like donald trump in that she tweets
bombastic things gets a bunch of
attention for herself and she loves it
the difference is i think donald trump
is naturally like this
i think he he really did have plans and
he wanted to do things for this country
and we had a great economy over the past
several years we have these historic
peace agreements
and then you have aoc who in my opinion
seems to be just trying to get
as many followers and i guess attention
as possible
the backlash that we saw in the last
election to defund the police to the
to talk about socialism to all the focus
on supposed systemic american racism
i think that backlash really did
materialize uh i think that there was
also a pretty significant backlash to
exactly the sort of cancer culture that
you're talking about i think most
americans
you're exactly right don't turn on the
news at night and wonder what somebody
said on twitter but they do see at their
own companies the ones that they work at
that so many of the elites at the top of
our corporate world have decided to buy
into the cancel culture mentality where
unless you personally post a black
square on your facebook page
you are now called into question if you
if you don't repeat
if you don't see and repeat and believe
then you are now a suspect
and if you say the wrong thing at the
office the canceled culture comes free
you might find yourself
on twitter one day so it's not that
twitter is a place for gathering and
trading ideas
twitter is a place for coming after you
and so whoever uses twitter that way
whoever uses the the political mechanism
that way
i think there's a huge backlash brewing
to this because the left has decided
that they're going to shut the overton
window they're going to shut it tight
they're going to wish all their enemies
out into the cornfield
and then they believe that this is
somehow going to achieve them a majority
i think that trump was just the
beginning of the backlash he may not
have been a great vehicle for the
backlash because he's such a flawed
character in and of himself
but the backlash is not going to stop
just because you know democrats believe
they've defeated trump
i completely agree yeah i think you're
right i think to to kind of just uh you
know
clarify my point i think regular people
don't care about these specific issues
of like white patriarchy and
you know recognizing your white
privilege but now they're being
subjected to it like you said so
they end up going to work being brought
into these training sessions
and they don't like it i mean it was it
was a trope for so long
we make fun of the the the you know the
um
sexual harassment workplace videos it's
a it's a comedy bit
but now you've got people actually being
forced to live through this
and they are scared of cancer culture
and that's the big problem i see with
the democrats they're entertaining it at
a policy level
as if anybody likes this i gotta be
honest i don't even think the leftists
who participate like it
i think they're all standing in the mob
with pitchforks nervously shaking
wondering which one is going to point
the finger at them
and they're safer in the mob than being
the target of the mob
i totally agree with this and this is
where social media really does get
dangerous not just because of its
ability to to
mobilize mobs i've stated that when it
comes to social media
it used to be that in order to form a
mob you usually had to have a cause
very often was a horrible cause but you
had to have at least a point of
commonality and then it was like okay
let's get together the mob and let's go
do x bad thing
now social media is just a mob waiting
for a cause it's just a bunch of people
milling around
waiting for a it's almost like a a badly
a badly motivated immune system where
we'll just identify the cell everybody
swarm
and and that that is a huge problem
obviously
i i also deeply concerned about the way
that social media has decided
that they are simply going to suppress
information they don't like uh and this
is this goes back to the the points
about antifa and blm
uh you had this this very famous
exchange with some of the big tech heads
on joe rogan's show where you were just
pointing out to them that they have no
consistent standards by which they
suppress certain people
and suppress certain content that they
are just doing this basically
out of their ass i mean they're just
coming up with this policy completely
out of nowhere and then just
implementing it but it seems to always
skew to one side it's never as though
they make the mistake of oops we banned
louis farrakhan
it's more like oops we banned this
person we banned james woods for a day i
guess we shouldn't abandon james woods
for a day okay fine
i guess we can bring back james woods or
you know what let's all get together
and you know alex jones he's been
bothering us for a while so we will all
together at the same time decide
just spontaneously that we are getting
rid of alex jones not because he has
necessarily violated our policies but
because we have decided that we don't
like alex jones anymore now listen
as you as everybody knows i am no alex
jones fan but you don't just all get to
get together and decide they're going to
change your standards randomly and then
ban alex jones because you don't like
alex jones that day
and expect that we are going to have
trust in your obj your objectivity
or your status as a neutral platform for
ideas
yeah it's the uh it's the ben shapiro
and tim agree show thanks for joining us
but uh
i agree i agree uh alex think about this
why was alex jones banned from all these
platforms it's
because of one thing he said uh
one topic he brought up and he brought
it up a couple times about sandy hook
because of this years later they
resurfaced these claims and demand he be
censored
from every single platform i think jones
has been around for three decades
i think he said some really crazy things
especially on joe rogan's podcast
but the idea that you could have three
decades of work
purged from the internet for saying one
bad thing
on a few occasions that's crazy imagine
if
you get a scientist who's talking about
the importance of
you know mask wearing or um best ways to
prevent covet
and then you know a month later he says
some off-color joke so they purge him
completely from social media
all of the important things he's done
are gone as well not that i'm here to
defend alex jones's body of work
i honestly don't really watch it or know
much about it other than when i see
those viral clips of him saying kind of
crazy things
but the idea that you would eliminate
someone from the internet forever
and just over saying one thing one time
or even if it was like three strikes
you're out i think that's crazy
you know one of the things that jack
dorsey said to me when i was talking
about the jorgen podcast was
we talked about a path to redemption
never happened
i it's crazy to me that you could break
the rules on twitter and they say you're
permanently banned
for life it's like we don't even do that
in the real world
for most things you go to prison we give
you a time limit
and then you can come back later on they
don't they don't allow that i think the
other really
important thing though when you bring up
the uh you know twitter's arbitrary
rules
is i think one of the big reasons why
they're banning conservatives
more than they ban the left is because
they live in that bubble they're all
very far left in silicon valley
and and you know wherever where they
make the rules they don't interact with
conservatives
or even moderates for that matter so
when they have parents who are moderates
and they say they're far right or
whatever
to them it's abnormal and it's offensive
and we must remove the offensive things
the best example of this
which i brought up to jack dorsey and
this is now what like two years ago
almost
the misgendering policy on twitter they
said
if you misgender someone you can be
banned but that's a world
view of a very tiny percentage of people
i was like you're basically creating a
rule
that upholds the world view of eight
percent of the population
if we go by the yougov data then about
eight percent are progressive activists
the rest are not
so if you're telling people this is the
real world do things this way
and you don't realize that you actually
represent the extreme minority
well then you're going to start banning
regular people calling them far right
you're going to say we're not biased
we're only getting rid of those who
break the rules
but your rules would be broken by
literally anybody i mean if you go to a
regular person
uh an average person just walking down
the street and ask them about
misgendering they're gonna say i don't
know what that is
if they sign up for twitter they'll get
banned right away and i've met people
who this has happened to i've met so
many people
who have only a few a small amount of
followers maybe a couple dozen maybe 100
or so their friends and their family
and they'll post something and get
banned and have no idea why
we don't live in this far left woke
bubble with these people
now i think for people like you and me
ben we
we can see their world we we we watch
the news we see what they're saying so
we get it
most people don't and so these rules
make no sense for the average person
long story short you end up with
advertising brands
that see how people are behaving on
social media and they assume this is
popular discourse
these ideas make sense but they don't
and regular people are confused by them
but once you get advertising agencies
buying into this stuff once you get
movies buying into this stuff
it can cause a cultural shift i am i am
starting to wonder though if the get
what go broke phenomenon is going to
cost
you know so much money for these
companies they realize we can't keep
chasing after the woke crowd on twitter
i certainly hope that that's the case i
think that may only be the case if
enough americans are offended enough not
to actually go by the products because
we we do have a process of what uh
nicholas seemed to leave called
renormalization happening
where you have a small minority that is
extremely motivated and
everybody else is just not as motivated
and so the small minority can move the
entire
the entire train just by basically
saying we care super a lot about this
issue and we're going to irritate the
living crap out of you
and and if you guys just leave us alone
just give us what we want then we'll
basically go away and i think that
you're seeing this taken to the extreme
there will come a point however when i
think people are just like you know what
no
it doesn't matter that this is a quote
unquote minor offense you you stack up
the minor offenses and eventually you
get to
this is just one giant basic major
offense against my sense of truth and
the facts and and propriety and i think
that's what's happening right now
i think the media have also picked up on
the mainstream media particularly the
establishment media
they've picked up on the silicon valley
bias and now they are using it to their
advantage their woke staffers inside
these silicon valley outlets and these
woke staffers are running the show
they really are in the same way that the
woke staffers at the new york times are
running the show and getting op-ed
editors fired for printing u.s
senators op-eds if you talk to any of
the people in the top levels of tech
they will tell you that their woke
staffers are driving them up a wall and
that they are creating all sorts of
problems
they're creating liability issues for
them and yet they won't stand up to the
woke staffers and so what you get now
is not just the pressure from inside you
have this inside outside game that i've
identified since
obviously i run a major conservative
publication and we've had our
experiences being suppressed
at yeah at extreme at extreme depth
uh by social media there's this inside
outside game that's being played now
where members of the mainstream media
people like kevin roos over at the new
york times people like kara swisher at
the new york times or judd legum
right where they spend their days
attempting to quote unquote ask
questions of tech bros that goes
something like this here is a bad thing
a conservative said why don't you ban
them
and it's every single day and very often
it's not even a bad thing that a
conservative said
it's just you guys are helping
conservatives and they tie this all into
orange hitler right they always talk
about orange man bad
facebook got donald trump elected
therefore that's because you allowed
conservative content to fly free on
facebook you really should suppress
conservative content
and so just this week we saw this
incredible
exchange with kevin russo the new york
times where he tweeted out four
headlines
and he said these headlines are
misinformation and they're flying around
they're flying around facebook every
single headline was true
all four headlines were true it was two
from breitbart it was one from
daley wire and i believe it was one from
daily caller all four were true and when
i said to him
dude all four of those are true those
are not misinformation he said
even if they are factually true they can
push a narrative that is untrue
and so they are misinformation which
just gives away the game i mean we
basically have establishment media
saying if you don't mirror our political
priorities
you are now deemed misinformation and
we'll use our fact-checking brand to
fact check you
and we will use our power in order to
leverage all the social media outlets
into shutting down anyone who is not the
new york times
i i love it because kevin roose ran this
story on
uh for the new york times it was a front
page story about how youtube
radicalized some guy to the alt-right
when in reality if you actually
read the story it was about a
traditional conservative who went on
youtube
started watching videos and then
eventually became a liberal
because youtube moved him left there's a
lot of data that actually shows youtube
has a left bias
they don't wanna a lot of these people
like like bruce don't wanna admit it
because
they want power this guy kevin rose is
an activist he's he's not a journalist
and i know him personally
and i can i can attest to this when i
worked for fusion
he worked there as well i think he was
the managing editor there was an issue
that came up where there was an
unprecedented
i believe unprecedented um social media
ethics violation that occurred from the
new york times
it was when ellen powell was the ceo
of reddit and she stepped down the story
was breaking news
the new york times wrote a story that
said ellen powell ceo
resigns that was basically it it became
one of the highest ranking posts on
reddit of all time
but overnight the new york times changed
the entire article
to something like silicon valley 2
social justice 0 or
feminism 0 and then the whole article
wasn't breaking news
they used the same url to turn it into
an analysis
op-ed about sexism in silicon valley
that's a that's an ethical violation a
journalistic violation and an internet
violation
you don't just change the url but news
organizations do this a lot
they're supposed to put updated you know
editors note here the changes we
made and let people know it's one thing
in my opinion
if a news outlet says you know here's a
headline and then we add information and
put we updated to add this
it's another thing when they changed 85
of the article turning a factual news
article
into an op-ed so i see this story and i
reach out to
some moderators at reddit and i ask them
what the rules are on various subreddits
for news outlets that do these things
and they said straight up this is a huge
violation and we don't know what to do
it was like the num the third most
upvoted story ever
and so they determined ultimately it had
to be removed the new york times
violated like this core tenet of
journalism and internet
i guess ethics when i said at fusion i
found this big story this is crazy look
what's happening
kevin roose told me don't report it
because we do the same thing
and we don't want to get called out for
our unethical behavior either
to paraphrase so this guy in my
experience has routinely and repeatedly
engage in activities that are not
intended to inform people
but to misinform people when he did that
new york times story on youtube
radicalization
they had this graphic where when you
when you loaded the website and scrolled
down
they had a big you know a collage of
youtubers that would slowly disappear
and my favorite was that philip defranco
was on it and philip defranco
is a um very i don't know how to
describe him
other than a a straightforward pop
culture and news personality on youtube
he's not very political at all
but they made it so that periodically
when you're scrolling down
it said i had been radicalized and it
shows philip defranco clearly misleading
people
so then they had to go in and say oh no
that was a mistake they had to change it
but the point was their narrative was
completely false
what i see there was that he wrote an
article trying to
smear his competition because the new
york times is losing viewership to
facebook video to facebook posts and to
youtube videos
so the new york times has a vested
interest in targeting their rivals
plus he's an activist he's very clearly
aligned with the ideological left
and you can even if you look at him on
twitter you can see he interacts with
with far left you know and antifa type
people all the time
when you have news organizations that
are more interested
in culture war rage bait to make money
or
when they're infiltrated by activists
then things are going to start getting
bad because
you don't know what's true anymore you
get a guy like kevin roos saying
these stories are misinformation now all
now people who follow him see it they
say oh those those
dangle right wingers putting out lies
again even though it was all true
and i think one of the craziest stories
that just happened recently was
washington post
saying that uh our i think richard
hopkins is his name the
postal service whistleblower recanted
his allegations the dude puts out a
video right away saying no i didn't
the washington post still runs the
headline saying he did i
think i think that the media in this
country for for a variety of reasons has
become completely invested
in just activism so i i will tell you
there is one thing that does excite me
if joe biden ends up you know being the
actual
inaugurated president is that the media
will spiral out of control and implode
with nothing to write about anymore
yeah this is this i think their greatest
fear and and i think they're going to
have to craft
uh a whole set of new villains but none
of them are ever going to be able to
take the place of
president trump of course was the
apotheosis of all evil on earth and an
orange miasma
of sin and terribleness uh and and
actually the physical embodiment of kofi
that was my favorite narrative over the
course of this past year is we have a
disease that
that kills hundreds of thousands now
over a million people
worldwide and it's all trump's fault
according to both joe biden and the
democratic media
if it were not for for donald trump no
one in america would have died
actually zero people in america would
have died meanwhile andrew cuomo the
governor of new york
is absolutely incredible at handling of
it in fact he wrote an entire book about
how great he is at handling covet
and made an entire poster that you could
buy and put on your wall about how
amazing he is at handling covet also by
the way
new york is now having a second spike
that is necessitating apparently
uh a lockdown let's talk about coveted
policy for a second because you've
covered it again in in sort of a
straightforward and
heterodox fashion there was all this
talk very early on
about the necessity for lockdowns
quickly this thing became quite
politicized as
i mentioned here the media's narrative
was this is all the right wing's fault
uh and it's all donald trump's fault
because donald trump is not
focusing in on mass squaring because
mass going is apparently a silver bullet
and also trump was doing public events
uh it depends on the public event covet
is an extraordinarily woke and wise
virus it only affects right-wing
right-wingers and orthodox jews those
are the only people that covet affects
if you are
if you are a black person who is
protesting uh the systemic cruelty of
the police it does not affect you if you
are a
a white lib who is uh who's cheering on
joe biden's
supposed victory by drinking out of the
same champagne bottle as three others it
doesn't affect you either
uh so uh obviously yeah the american
trust in the media on covet is at an
all-time low
i think it should be at an all-time low
what do you make of of the media
coverage of coven where do you think
we're at on this thing
i think i look i think we can clearly
see the spikes there's uh very real data
showing that
this year we had way more expected
mortality than normal
you know i'm not a big fan of these you
know like the conspiracy theories and
stuff
there's obviously you know covet going
on and i think it's ridiculous that i
have to even have to say that but we're
at that point
the problem is i blame the mainstream
media for this
because if you've got you know that
there's viral videos going of
you know memes showing all of these
celebrations for joe biden being
declared president-elect
and like you mentioned they're sharing
champagne i love it when joe biden
pulled his mask down to coffin to his
hand
it's they don't they don't take this
seriously they don't know what they're
doing they don't
they don't they don't care even you've
got i think it was
it was a world health organization
doctor saying no more lockdowns
should be a last resort let's not do
this again it's it's really dangerous
because
economic damage leads to death as well
now you've got cuomo
and and murphy in new jersey instituting
more lockdowns it doesn't quite make any
sense
it's almost like they're locking things
down
because they're scared of the media not
the actual virus
they don't want to be they don't want to
be said that they're responsible for the
death
because hey if we lock down then any
problems that arise in the lockdown is
because we had to do it but if they
don't lock down they'll blame them for
you know for
for virus tests i think i think we've
created a
a mass hysteria around this if you look
at the mortality rate of kovid it is
bad it's a it's a it's a a bit worse
than the flu
i'm not going to pretend like it's
substantially worse but it is higher
it's not the same as the flu it's it's a
lot higher and there's lingering uh
effects that come from it
but for the most part you're only
allowed to tell people the end is nigh
you know if i remember early on on
youtube they made a rule that you
couldn't talk about covet at all they
would demonetize you
the only news we end up getting is going
to say something like
people are going to die unless we lock
things down if you come out and say
well i think the lockdown could be worse
they say you want to kill grandma or
something
so they've created the media has created
a social pressure to encourage people to
claim we must take the most extreme
action possible that's not healthy
if we can't have someone come out and
say hey we looked at the data here's
what we found
we should chill out you can't really do
that i mean you kind of can
but the incentive is to claim the world
is burning down
so what happens politicians respond to
it by locking things down
regular people put on masks when they're
in their own bathrooms and they panic
i've seen some people react in crazy
ways over mask wearing i was just riding
my bike
um i'm i'm in a forest preserve
essentially
alongside a river there's no one
anywhere and i see people riding bikes
with masks on
i just found that to be very strange
you're by yourself in the woods
riding a bike you need to breathe but
you put a mask on it's
it's because the only news they're
getting is this is the end
i'll tell you what's really funny about
all this i've invited
numerous leftists to come onto my
podcast uh tim cast irl which is a sit
down conversation you know kind of like
what we're doing here
conservatives will do it in two seconds
um moderate right-wing individuals
uh even you know disaffected liberals
who find themselves safe voting for
trump
they'll say fly me out we take all the
precautions you know where we we
we treat it seriously but we're not
cowering from it
but i reach out to some of these
prominent uh higher you know uh
leftists on social media and stuff and
they say i'm too scared of covid to
travel
so it's clearly affecting democrats and
and the left and
you know actual uh well i don't say
actual liberals or whatever the the
resistance left has become
they're mortified of this and it's it's
it's
i don't i don't i don't know what's
going to happen but i tell you if you've
got
two factions you know which don't i
don't want to act like everyone on the
right or
even in a you know even who uh or like
anti woke crowd
like they agree and everything but if
they can agree on the fact that we can
still
do our jobs and function they're going
to generate more wealth they're gonna be
more successful
they're going to live their lives and be
happier these these people on the left
who are terrified of the virus because
what they're hearing in the media over
and over again
they're not going out and working
they're demanding government you know
cut checks to them
i imagine they're not going to succeed
not going to improve their skills in
fact
sitting inside locked up all day is
probably going to dull their abilities
i think it's going to create this weird
disparity and skill cap and wealth at
some point
but ultimately i think it's just the
media trying to make money
and they're going to chase after the
horrifying narrative until they drive
off the cliff
and you're certainly seeing that with
regards to the schools where the only
people who currently are going to
schools
are people either in red states or
people who can afford to send their kids
to private school and if you are
if you are poor and living in in
washington dc you are just screwed they
are going to force you to put your kid
on a zoom school that your kid will not
attend and they will learn nothing
and uh apparently the media just don't
care so tim i want to ask a few final
questions
starting with you voted for donald trump
you're an independent center-left guy i
want to ask why you voted for donald
trump but if you'd like to hear tim
pool's answers you have to be a daily
wire member go to dailywire.com click
join at the top of the page you can hear
the rest of our conversation
over there now tim poole it's been a
pleasure thanks so much for coming on
the show and
i'm going to direct everyone to go and
check out tim's stuff
on youtube at tim cast and tim cast irl
as well as timcast.com tim
really appreciate you stopping by thanks
so much thanks for having me
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo
the ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.